[Music]
in a few weeks the new mcu series miss
marvel will be released on disney plus
there's hardly any time left to promote
the mcu debutant disney must have
thought so too thus last tuesday they
shared another poster via twitter
showing all the main characters of the
series together the content is as in the
comic book original about the muslim
school girl kamala khan who has to deal
with the typical problems of a teenager
pressure to perform anxiety about the
future and her first great love as you
can easily tell from the superhero name
she emulates her great role model
captain marvel about whom she regularly
writes fanfiction one day her wish for
her own superpowers comes true and she
is faced with much bigger problems after
all life with these powers is not quite
so simple in addition to imandolania's
kamala khan we will also be able to see
aramis knight saga shike risha and many
other not yet quite so well known actors
in the series gathering behind the
camera will be showrunner and writer
bishop k ali along with four directors
adila larbi bilal fala mera manan and
charmin obai chinoy ms marvel will be
available on disney plus starting june 8
2022. it's not only stock brokers who
have been rejoicing recently in view of
the billion dollar merger between warner
brothers in dc movie fans can also look
forward to the near future the new
company warner brothers discovery is now
run by discovery boss david zeslov who
has big plans for the dc universe
apparently he wants to max out the full
potential of the dc comics characters
together with the previous dc boss
walter yamada since 2018 hemata has been
in an executive position at dc and can
chalk up major successes such as joker
from 2019. in addition the strategy
pursued under him was to also conceive a
streaming spin-off for every dc film if
possible as can be seen in peacemaker or
the upcoming penguin series for example
however zazzlef is said to particularly
have cast an eye on superman as the
character is in urgent need of revival
and is accordingly at the top of the
priority list the new boss is also
believed to be currently on the outlook
for a counterpart to marvel boss kevin
feige who for years has ensured that all
mcu movies and series are linked
together and keeps production running
smoothly we are excited to see how the
dc universe will develop under the new
management and look forward to much more
content from the likes of superman
batman and others in the future
many were looking forward to spider-man
across the spider-verse this year but
sadly the sequel to into the
spider-verse will not be out until next
year as sony announced the movie around
miles morales has been postponed from
october 2022 to june 2nd 2023 and the
follow-up to it will then be released on
march 29th 2024 other sony movies are
also affected by rescheduling including
for example lyle crocodile which will
now take the place of spider-man across
the spider-verse on october 7th 2022.
regarding two other films there is now
an official release date one for madame
web on july 7th 2023 and the other for
the equalizer 3 on september 1st 2023
many fans are annoyed by the
significantly longer waiting period for
spider-man across the spider-verse
however it must also be said that this
sequel will have to follow in very big
footsteps next year the second part is
to be shown in theaters with a plant
release date of june 2nd we will know
more as soon as the next trailer comes
out at the latest in june 2023 when the
film hits theaters
a minecraft movie has been in the works
since 2014 but not much has happened in
the past few years the last time variety
reported about the potential plot of the
film was almost precisely three years
ago which was said to revolve around a
teenage girl who has to face the
notorious ender dragon together with her
friends now the hollywood reporter
shares more news about the long term
project according to sources aquaman
star jason momoa has spent sign on for
the lead role in the movie under the
direction of jaron hass however momoa
will not be seen as a pixelated and
blocky hero but as a normal live-action
character this has already been
confirmed in the past by the minecraft
studio mojang as they didn't want a
movie that was too close to the video
game original otherwise the result would
be an endless movie with few details in
fact the options for telling a classic
story in the minecraft universe while
staying close to the original seem
almost impossible exactly when the film
will be released in theaters and whether
the information about the plot is still
up to date is unfortunately not known at
the moment
as we recently reported filming on the
witcher season 3 has been ongoing since
the beginning of this month and those
responsible recently announced by
twitter a total of four new actors who
will enrich the story resident evil
welcome to raccoon city actor robbie
amal plays galadin the warrior of this
coyote who goes into battle for
nilfgaard as the antagonist of the elven
sorceress francesca amell is joined by
shanghi and the legend of the 10 rings
actress manger zhang who embodies the
talented archer milva the cast also
features les miserables actor hugo
skinner as prince wrote of it son of
king bismir and without question the
playboy of the royal family lastly
there's the young star crystal alvin who
has only been seen in bloods and royal
shakespeare company much ado about
nothing she will play the teenage
missile who is a member of the infamous
gang of rats said gang follows a sort of
weird robin hood aethers stealing from
the sometimes more and sometimes less
wealthy in order to enrich themselves so
far it sounds pretty promising we're
definitely curious to see how big the
roles of the new characters are going to
be and we will keep you posted on
further information from the shooting
many know the brand exploding kittens
either as a card or mobile game netflix
also seems to have noticed the
popularity of the exploding cats and as
a result the twitter account netflix
geek announced the cast for the planned
comedy series and animation format this
past monday a matching game is also
supplied by netflix directly it is
slightly different from the one already
available and is planned for release
this may the voice actors for the series
will include lucifer actor tom ellis
rhodes and bridges actor abraham lim and
ally mackie who already excelled as
giggle make dimples in toy story 4. the
office producer greg daniels and silicon
valley creator mike judge are in charge
of production in terms of content
exploding kittens revolves around a duel
between god and the devil that is fought
through the bodies of obese cats on
earth that sounds pretty funky so we are
eagerly awaiting more news this series
is scheduled for release on netflix
later in 2023
last year netflix was still expecting
2.5 million new users in the first
quarter of 2022 but in the meantime the
responsible parties are looking at
considerably alarming figures for the
first time since october 2011 the
streaming giant has lost more
subscribers than it has gained with
nearly 200 000 users lost globally in
addition the stock price plunged by more
than 30 percent which not only gives
shareholders an uneasy feeling
reportedly the first high-ranking
employee has already had to leave the
company the dogs of phil rinder who used
to be the head of creative development
at the animation department the top
management of netflix in particular has
been under fire when it comes to dealing
with employees from the animation branch
it is said that entire projects have
been dropped several times simply
because the people in charge were not
pleased with the user statistics even if
the films and series were highly praised
by critics and audiences talented
screenwriters and animation specialists
will do it with unequal freedom only to
discover that the slightest deviation
from previously operated figures put an
end to their work in fact struggling
in-house productions are being
unconditionally canceled rather than
supported by netflix further damaging
the streaming service image others
though suspect that the causes of the
disastrous collapse and subscriber
numbers are external factors such as the
ukraine crisis or the services
suspension in russia also the tests
currently underway in the south american
country such as chile costa rica and
peru to increase the pricing of shared
netflix accounts are not met with
enthusiasm in addition a system is being
planned in which users pay a slightly
lower price but see adds in return none
of this seems to be well received by
customers so many are switching to
competitors like disney plus or amazon
prime video after all the selection of
streaming services is larger than ever
in 1999 the surprise hit the blair witch
project generated the record-breaking
sum of 248 million us dollars with an
almost ridiculous budget of 60 000
the movie was not only a milestone in
horror film history in terms of sales
revenue however but also with regard to
its method of production the found
footage technique inspired later films
like paranormal activity and cloverfield
and was able to breathe new life into
the horror genre after the two films
book of shadows and blair witch 3 were
neither financially nor atmospherically
as convincing as the original lion's
gate is now working on another sequel
according to jeff snyder of the ankler
fans of the original movie meanwhile are
hoping for the involvement of the blair
witch project directors daniel myrick
and ederardo sanchez who were only
marginally involved in the two sequels
given snyder's tweet it is considered
likely that the new blair witch film
will get a streaming release and this
won't be running in theaters at all we
are still waiting for an official
confirmation of the rumor anyway and are
going to keep you up to date
that's it for the news this week if
you're a mcu fan you should definitely
watch the new trailer for thor love and
thunder on the channel as it has finally
released and by the way if you haven't
been to the movie theater yet to watch
the bad guys or you can't decide whether
it is even a good idea to give it a go
then you might be interested in watching
our 6 minute clip that shows the opening
scene of the film you won't regret it it
is truly amusing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]